so tell me about this toy this is really
exciting you and I work together already
on the single and you know how did you
know that he wanted you to come out with
him well I mean I think just organically
after doing the song together seeing
blind on his album it just made sense to
do a tour he's never done a solo artists
tour at this capacity and I feel like
our music styles really complement each
other so it just it made sense and it's
been one of the most fun tours I think
I've been on yeah is it do you get a
thrill when you're out there in front of
the crowd and they're singing like rich
back to you yeah I do I don't think that
ever gets old if it does get old then
you should probably just call it quits
because that's a big part of it is just
the audience interaction and you know
you never think when you write a song a
couple years prior that people are gonna
know the words and freak out when they
hear the first chord ring out so that's
always fun yeah speaking of interaction
you're really active on on social media
I left how open you are on Twitter and
on Instagram recently I love what you
did here you called out someone that was
body shaming you that was that was being
a real hater right and kind of put them
in the place started for yourself what
what compelled you why did you feel it
was important to to get out there cuz
whenever you say something on social
media all your fanbase is watching so
closely
I guess what compels me to respond
I don't always respond to those sort of
trolls because you know that's kind of
what they're wanting is just a reaction
but when it comes to stuff like you know
body dysmorphia body shaming especially
with women from men
I don't know it just strikes a nerve and
me and I know that there's a lot of
young kids watching what I do and the
way I conduct myself which is very open
and independent and kind of free
thinking I yeah for some reason the body
shaming thing I feel like there's just
no room for it in society ever and
everyone's just trying to be a better
version of themself and there's just you
know it's just I think if people and
fans and young fans see me react in a
powerful way to people body shaming or
just being negative I feel like that
will I don't know maybe trickle down and
inspire them to stand up to like the
school bully or to whoever whomever is
you know they're they're facing
adversity with so yeah I I sometimes
respond and my own way to those idiots
and you seem to be embracing that role
of being a role model which i think is
really great and it's also gives your
fans someone to look up to what does
that mean to you to have that position
as a role model well I think being a
role model is sort of a byproduct of
just being yourself and I think my fans
really gravitate to that and I think
that I I try not to put too much
pressure on it because the whole reason
I think a lot of them have been inspired
by me whether it's my music or the way
that I sort of perceived on social media
or interviews is that I
I'm just myself and I feel like they
they want to be like that too they want
to be themselves and so if that's like
what has made me a role model I think
that I can continue doing that without
any pressure because I'm just being
meirin and I don't really think I could
be anyone else so I kind of take it as
an honor but also not a heavy crown to
wear yeah
now those fans have been following your
success for years now you've had so much
up to this point but this has been a
real banner year for you
you know you've been able to reach out
to a whole new audience with your
collaboration was that have you felt the
difference yeah I mean I don't know how
it lined up this way but doing the song
with Zedd with the middle and then being
on this tour with nyle which is a pop
tour which I haven't really done yeah
it's been a crazy year simultaneously
with my own country stuff still
happening and I'm on my last single for
my debut album right now rich and yeah
so to sort of weave in this pop world
throughout my year has been really cool
it's like a new challenge for me and I
think it's opened up a lot of pop fans
and international fans to my music but
also the world of country music which is
very cool yeah it's been so fun to be a
part of both of those things it seems to
be going both ways and there's there's a
lot of crossover now do you think that
that that sort of will break down the
barriers of how people think about music
like country fans just being country
fans and pop fans not really considering
country music but you're breaking that
barrier down essentially well thanks I
would hope it breaks barriers down
because I I say this in a lot of my
shows because my album isn't just one
thing it's not just country it's not pop
it's not just R&B or bluegrass I mean
it's just a bunch of different stuff
because that's how I was raised
and I think most of us listen to more
than one genre of music I mean if you
only listen or order one thing off the
menu each day you're going to get
you know tired of it I want to open
people up to not being ashamed to love
everything and I think honestly with
streaming services it's broken a lot of
those boundaries down just organically
because people can just bounce to
different playlists genre to genre and
it's just about good music it's not
about the genre yeah